c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas
inhabituel les suspensions que ce soit
en commission mix paréire ou en
commission tout court ça arrive lorsque
les groupes ont besoin de réfléchir à
quelque chose d'imprévu manifestement
les discussions n'étaient pas encore
terminées donc c'est pas quelque chose
qui entraîne des crises de nerf chez les
députés ou chez les Sénateurs il y a un
point visiblement qui centralise
beaucoup de problème c'est la question
des appels les aides pour le logement
comment est-ce que vous comprenez tout
ce yatus autour de ce point précis c'est
pas parce que le point est plus
important que d'autres parce que tous
les points de cette loi sont importants
c'est simplement parce que dans les
discussions entre la première ministre
et certains groupes et notamment le
groupe des Républicains ce sujet a été
considéré comme abordés par les uns et
pas abordé par les autres parce com
comprendre ceatus entre les deux camps
parce que le problème c'était de savoir
si les appels était considéré comme une
prestation sociale comme les autres ou
quelque chose de spécial les uns ont
compris que ça en faisait partie les les
autres on pris le contraire c'était une
discussion orale et le jour au moment où
elle été actée par écrit on s'est rendu
compte que la position divergit très
franchement sur l'ensemble des 80
articles à peu près de cette loi il y a
27 articles mais au total il y en a
environ 80 c'est un sujet extrêmement
ponctuel si le débat ne porte
aujourd'hui à ce stade que sur ce luà on
va bien le voir dans dans courant de la
nuit mais si ça porte que sur celui-là
c'est quand même quelque chose qui
devrait se résoudre et donc pas de quoi
faire échouer la mission mixte paritaire
ce serait pas une ligne rouge valable
dans le camp Renaissance ou chez les LR
selon vous je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui peut être l'objet d'un
compromis comme beaucoup d'autres
articles on ét l'objet d'un compromisun
compromis sur la sur par exemple sur la
durée de présence pour bénéficier des
aPL de la même façon que la durée de
présence pour bénéficier des prestations
sociales donc on a trouvé un compromis
sur les prestations sociales il y a pas
de raison qu'on en trouve pas sur les
APL maintenant à partir de là si on en
fait une posture politique bien entendu
on peut toujours trouver trouver un
point mais à ce stade de la soirée je
pense plutôt je suis plutôt optimiste
sur le fait que ce point ne devrait pas
être un point de blocage une dernière
question si vous le voulez bien vous
avez parlé avec Madame born quand pour
la dernière fois est-ce que vous faites
partie de la majorité est-ce que vous
avez pu lui parler par exemple
aujourd'hui elle veut un accord jusqu'au
bout non moi j'ai participé à la réunion
d'hier soir je me rappelle plus quelle
heure il est si on est mardi
ou lundi donc dimanche soir
je pas recacté pas ni étéonacté par
Madame bien sûr qu'elle veut un accord
bien sûr et bien merci merci Claude
malur pour cette réaction en direct au
micro de
publiccp